- Brother, (laughs)
anything goes in Florida.
♪ Hello Lakeland ♪
♪ Y'all ready to rock
in the Sunshine State ♪
♪ They got rednecks wrestling' pythons ♪
♪ They got drunk girls goin' wild ♪
♪ Party with margaritavillers ♪
♪ And serial killers ♪
♪ While you watch a gator eat a child ♪
♪ They proudly lead the nation ♪
♪ In public masturbation ♪
♪ They're jerkin' off all over the place ♪
♪ Forget the Key lime pie ♪
♪ Let's get a bath salt high ♪
♪ And munch on a stranger's face ♪
♪ Because anything goes in Florida ♪
♪ Come on down and do your worst ♪
♪ Snort a rail off a dolphin ♪
♪ Naked and a-golfin' ♪
♪ Chances are you won't be the first ♪
♪ Doing anything, anywhere ♪
♪ Any time in F-L-A ♪
♪ They got meth labs and Magic Kingdoms ♪
♪ Titty bars and the KKK ♪
♪ And when shit goes down ♪
♪ You can stand your ground ♪
♪ And blow your neighbor away ♪
♪ Because anything goes in Florida ♪
♪ Baby, let the good times roll ♪
♪ If there's a law, you can duck it ♪
♪ If you catch it, you can fuck it ♪
♪ It's America's glory hole ♪
♪ Talkin' anything, anywhere ♪
♪ Any night and any day ♪
♪ In F-L-A ♪
- Wow, did you write that song?
- Yeah, I mean Vince Neil helped.
- Legitimately good song.
- Thanks, man.
- It makes a good point,
and you know what boy?
I'm gonna do it, I'm gonna
french my grandma's granddaughter.
- Woo hoo!